all right guys so let's start today i
want to talk about gme i want to talk
about triple q i want to talk quickly
about lucid as well so let's get into it
[Music]
so i'm gonna start with gme yesterday i
talked about amc i talked about spy and
i talked about the crypto market so guys
go watch this video if you haven't seen
it it's very interesting i'm explaining
why i believe a correction is about to
happen and what would be the impact on
amc uh right now i'm gonna do a bit the
same thing but with gme and i'm gonna
use triple q which is the nasdaq 100 etf
so it's a good tracker of the global
market of the tech sector especially
uh so first let's do some basic ta basic
technical analysis on gme so we have
here guys this huge triangle you have
seen this triangle for some time bam let
me get rid of that what happened here
guys what happened is that we all got
[ __ ] i'm sorry for the language but
this is what happened we got [ __ ] guys
here here not really because this is not
really a fake out we didn't close above
this is a pure fake out guys after
consolidation we had all the signals and
still the market didn't manage to go
higher also because uh there was some
issues in the global market so it's not
a full gme takeout but i mean it's not
looking good but what you need to
remember guys here is that whenever you
have those fake outs usually you have a
breakout okay so uh not a fake out in
the opposite direction this is what
happened here we faked out and then we
broke up on the downside this is a real
breakout retested as you guys can see
typical triangle breakout we come here
find some support at the previous lows
so it could have been higher it could
have been here but whatever we found
support here we rebounded
um this is my 160 level important level
and then we went lower so what can we
expect whenever those triangles are
broken just like for amc we can expect a
correction that lasts
between one third and one
full triangle so one third of this
triangle guys is already two three
months so we are only one month and a
half in this correction and the usual
patterns we see are abc's or wxy it can
be either abc is going deeper doing a 5
3 5 wave counting and w x y corrections
are doing sideways corrections so
something like this okay
this would be a w x y
and
this would be unfortunately an abc abc
okay so right now we did the a or the w
it it doesn't really matter wf should
have three waves a wave should should
have five
i don't know how many you count here you
can rather three one two three abc but
maybe the a wave is not complete you
know maybe this is the a wave all right
so it's it doesn't really matter what
matters is that we are in the corrective
pattern that should last two three
months okay let's quickly analyze what
happened after the nft news about gme
getting involved in the nft market
guys i was shocked i mean i was posting
my daily recap on vme like i do every
day and when i posted it i saw the post
market getting going higher higher
higher and i was i was like what is that
and i still don't fully understand what
happened here so basically if we zoom on
the one hour time frame
uh we had this crazy move that happened
on thursday post market after the news
and that went to 170. so what can it be
this is a low liquidity period and
it if the price goes up that strongly it
means that there are big sizes who is
trading big sizes it can be asset
managers it's not retail retail didn't
come after market buying like that right
so it's some i think institutional
clients or hedges if it's if we're
talking about hedges it means they would
have covered a short position because
those guys are short why would have they
done that during the past market when
they know there is a scarce liquidity
and that they will of course get a bad
level i don't think uh this is the way
they do things but maybe it's what we
call a fat finger so you know the guy
wanted to do a smaller position he did a
bigger position and he didn't get
executed before the close so he uh just
moved the market after the close it's
possible as well uh maybe it's some
people that got late for the close you
know those guys they usually trade
before the close when the liquidity is
there because they don't want to disturb
the market so
whatever it is it is probably a mistake
done by a professional
investor such as an asset manager or a
hedge fund maybe it's some hedge funds
like i said that covered some margin
calls but once again
they would have probably kept buying it
the day after and the price got you know
didn't hold
so how can we interpret this not good
guys uh 160 was the level to break
we didn't manage as you can see on the
daily time frame to get above that
160.3 is the maximum level we saw
this is a level that is pretty obvious
guys i mean i think that no one that is
doing technical analysis has missed that
level it's very obvious and this is the
level we need to break for bulls to take
back control on the short term we didn't
and we got civilly rejected that's
bearish right so we are bearish guys on
the medium term and we can expect
unfortunately the price action to go
maybe lower or maybe just sideways so if
we go lower i'm going to show you guys
the analysis on the triple q that is
going to help us but first abc pattern
we have the a wave i think is complete
we completed the b wave so we are doing
a c wave so for c waves guys you use
field projections you measure a wave you
apply it to the top of the b wave and
you check the one two one one two open
six one eight the most common one is one
two 0.618 and one to one here the 0.618
is going to 85 okay and we have some
support at 85. so double uh reason to
believe that if we have a c wave it
would go to 85. now the 120.382
is also a level and as you can see guys
it's funny to see that those levels you
know okay let's do it perfectly it's not
perfect but you know those levels
they're coming you know very
surprisingly to some support levels 85
115 so those are the levels to watch
either we go to 115 either we go to 85.
this is what we can expect unfortunately
for the coming weeks
after that of course he has a strong
rebound why because we've seen guys
how this two stocks amc gamestop are
able to rebound strongly whenever there
is
just a small news that investors are
just cheering for now what is gonna tell
us if we go to 85 or uh if we gonna be
able to go sideways it's the global
market if the global market is crashing
like 10 15 percent which is once again
go check the video i did yesterday
unfortunately gonna happen i think
within a week or uh maybe three months i
don't exactly know the timing but it's
gonna happen i think gme and amc would
go to you know 15 and 85 before strong
rebound so let's just be prepared for
that and now the analysis i'm gonna do
on the triple queue guys so triple q is
the nasdaq 100 etf so basically it's a
good indicator of the global market look
guys the very healthy trend that we had
how do you know if a trend is healthy
you check if you have hidden divergences
what is the hidden divergence is
whenever the market is making higher
lows uh yes so basically going higher
all right so whenever you see an amp
trend you just check if the market is
breathing enough so what does it mean to
breathe it means that the momentum is
making lower lows all right so we go
back the momentum is the energy we go
back take some energy so that we can
push higher this is a healthy trend
whenever the trend is healthy the uh
trend is likely to continue and we have
those continuation breakout okay now we
had this for one year and a half look
what we have right now since october 21
do you see the macd going lower do you
see it guys you know look here each time
we had
those bam here
low low connection on the trend line
lower low connection of the on the trend
line lower low connection on the trend
line so on and so forth and now
connection on the trend line but
high low so we don't have the hidden
bullish divergence anymore does it mean
that we're gonna break out on the doubt
side no but the probability is of course
higher second thing that makes me
believe that we're gonna break it soon
is that guys you remember what we saw
jamie whenever we have a fake out on the
upside then usually we have a downside
breakout look what happened here guys we
had a fake out here on the upside many
investors myself included got caught
here i bought some shares about many
different things here and you know i
just got hanged here on those trades
so i lost money so you know i feel like
you know you don't feel good so whenever
this happens usually you have a fake out
on the downside i personally took a
bearish position on the global market to
protect my investment on the spy around
one percent higher so not that much
higher and because i'm afraid that this
time we don't hold on 380 so guys the
level to watch is 380. if we break that
okay what can happen
maybe we're gonna find some support here
and then rebound but then we're gonna go
lower tag tag tag okay and here guys i'm
gonna be here to take a bearish position
to protect my investment and when what
i'm gonna do after that i'm gonna reload
on gme and amc at the levels i showed
you because if the global market is
correcting we're gonna go there then the
hedges they're gonna need to face some
margin requirements because they lose
money they're gonna charge something
that is consuming a lot of margin a amc
short gme short so this is i think a
good strategy that i'm personally gonna
put in place so that's it for today i
hope you guys enjoyed this video and if
you did please don't forget to click on
the sub like and bell button so you're
gonna be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to shore
i'll see you guys